bonjour Jean-Noël barreau vous êtes donc
ministre en charge de la transition
numérique et donc en charge du dossier
Tik Tok le réseau social chinois qui
cartonne dans le monde entier on le sait
environ 7 millions de Français se
connecte tous les jours sur Tik Tok en
particulier des ados et justement TikTok
a annoncé des mesures hier pour en
théorie protégée ces jeunes utilisateurs
une limite de 60 minutes quotidiennes
pour les moins de 18 ans est-ce que ce
matin vous dites bravo à Tik Tok ou
c'est juste un coup de com parce que les
ados seront facilement contournés cette
limitation la limitation à une heure
pour les moins de 18 ans est une avancée
qui était attendue mais elle est
bienvenu maintenant il faut que la
mobilisation s'accentue la mobilisation
des grandes plateformes pour mieux
protéger nos enfants en ligne contre les
effets
délétères d'une forme d'addiction aux
écrans qui est désormais de mieux en
mieux documenter et dont les les parents
font l'expérience au quotidien on a
beaucoup de témoignages depuis ce matin
justement de parents inquiets parfois
démuni face à Tik Tok j'en aurai en gros
une heure par jour sur Tik Tok c'est ce
que promet la plateforme ce serait la
limite pour les pour les jeunes mais une
heure par jour c'est largement suffisant
pour voir passer tout un tas de contenu
assez inquiétant je vais vous dire la
vérité j'ai testé hier pour la première
fois j'ai téléchargé TikTok j'ai passé
une demi-heure alors oui il y a des gens
qui dansent qui chantent c'est sympa
mais il y a aussi cette challenge ses
défis stupides il y a des vidéos parfois
violentes il y a aussi le phénomène des
influenceurs qui font la promotion de
produits parfois dangereux or moi je me
souviens très bien début janvier de
Bruno Le Maire qui avait annoncé qu'il
comptait prendre des mesures justement
pour encadrer les pratiques et les
dérives de ces influenceurs où est-ce
qu'on en est parce que c'était il y a
deux mois maintenant ces annonces où
est-ce qu'on en est aujourd'hui des
mesures concrètes pour limiter les les
pratiques des influenceurs il y a en
France à peu près 150000 influenceurs
avec des activités variées chacun a pu
le constater qui vont de la
vulgarisation scientifique au
divertissement en passant par le
bricolage le jardinage etc c'est une
activité nouvelle que certains ont
dévoyé volontairement ou
involontairement en dans les instruments
d'arnaque ou de publicité mensongères on
l'a vu encore récemment avec un
médicament sérieusement pour laquelle
que certains préconisent comme pour
maigrir tout simplement c'est d'avoir
dangereux pour la santé et puis ça crée
des tensions des pénuries sur le marché
pour ceux qui ont vraiment besoin de ce
médicament exactement ces raisons pour
laquelle Bruno Le Maire il y a quelques
mois a décidé de s'emparer du sujet avec
trois objectifs protéger les
consommateurs accompagner les
influenceurs qui ne sont pas tous qui ne
se livrent pas tous à des arnaques et
puis sanctionner les tricheurs il a
lancé une consultation 20 000 personnes
y ont participé 80 000 contributions ont
été recueillies ces contributions sont
aujourd'hui très telles font l'objet de
discussion avec les acteurs de ce
secteur là et fin mars des annonces
seront faites donc des mesures concrètes
pour encadrer les pratiques des
influenceurs mais consommateurs et ça ne
suffira pas en revanche pour limiter le
temps d'écran déjà là vous nous dites
TikTok c'est bien ça avance mais il faut
aller plus loin ça veut dire faire quoi
parce que j'ai l'impression que les
parents de leur côté font de leur mieux
les réseaux comme tik au fond des
annonces mais un peu cosmétiques sur ces
limitations que fait le gouvernement
pour protéger les mineurs la première
chose que nous faisons c'est que dans
quelques mois la France sera le premier
pays du monde à généraliser le contrôle
parental sur tous les appareils qui sont
vendus sur son sol des smartphones aux
consoles de jeux vidéo en passant par
les tablettes concrètement lorsque vous
achèterez un téléphone un smartphone en
France pour votre enfant le contrôle
parental sera préinstallé il restreindra
l'accès au site réservé aux adultes je
pense aussi de porno par exemple il vous
permettra de contrôler le temps passé
sur l'écran de vos enfants et puis vous
permettra de filtrer aussi un certain
nombre de sites et puis en parallèle
nous allons jouer une contrainte que
vous allez imposer aux fabricants de
smartphones tout à fait et c'est déjà le
cas puisque c'est une loi qui a été
votée il y a quelques années déjà mais
qui est pas encore appliquée vous avez
une date à partir de laquelle si je vais
acheter un téléphone dans une boutique
si je dis c'est pour mon ado il est
c'est par par définition préinstallée il
y aura une date à partir de là nous
attendons la validation définitive du
décret d'application du texte
d'application de cette loi et à partir
de là les les fabricants et les
distributeurs d'appareils devront et
puis en parallèle aujourd'hui même à
l'Assemblée nationale le les députés
vont débattre d'un texte qui impose à
ses réseaux sociaux de vérifier
sérieusement l'âge de leurs utilisateurs
vous savez qu'aujourd'hui TikTok a mis
une limite d'âge de 13 ans sur sa
plateforme or on sait très bien qu'il y
a encore beaucoup d'enfants de 8 à 12
ans qui sont inscrits sur Tik Tok et qui
passe un temps considérable et bien avec
cette proposition de loi que je soutiens
le Tik Tok et les autres réseaux sociaux
seront obligés non seulement de vérifier
l'âge des utilisateurs mais lorsque ces
utilisateurs ont moins de 15 ans de
recueillir également le consentement des
parents l'accord des parents pour que
les enfants puissent s'inscrire sur le
sur un réseau comme Tik Tok et que
risque le réseau s'il ne se conforme pas
à cette loi parce qu'on a l'impression
que ce sont des lois qu'on peut voter en
France mais que Tik Tok a un impact
mondial est-ce que vous avez vraiment le
moyen de leur tordre le bras de leur
infliger des amendes etc oui il y a un
régime de sanction est prévu par par la
proposition de loi et par ailleurs et de
combien c'est quoi les amendes
concrètement que risque TikTok s'il ne
se conforme pas à cette loi française
vous c'est les débats qui vont décider
il y a des amendements qui ont été
déposés sur les sanctions qui peuvent
être qui peuvent être soutenu par le
gouvernement aujourd'hui la proposition
loi est soutenue par le gouvernement et
je veux dire mieux que ça parce que
l'année dernière au niveau européen de
ce que vous avez raison les les géants
du numérique c'est au niveau européen
qu'il faut que nous leur imposions nos
règles et l'année dernière la France a
imposé de nouvelles règles qui sont en
train d'entrer en vigueur comme par
exemple l'interdiction de la publicité
ciblée sur les mineurs dans quelques
mois dans tous les États membres de
l'Union européenne tous les réseaux
sociaux auront l'interdiction de faire
de la publicité ciblée sur les mineurs
et si il ne se conforme pas à cette
interdiction il ils auront des pénalités
pouvant aller jusqu'à 6% de leur chiffre
d'affaires mondial pour une entreprise
comme Tik Tok c'est à peu près 300
millions d'euros d'amende et il y a une
autre inquiétude autour de Tik Tok parce
que Tik Tok est un réseau chinois et
Pékin
soupçonné d'aspirer les données des
internautes du monde entier grâce à Tik
Tok notamment des données sensibles on
parle presque d'espionnage aux
États-Unis Tik Tok est désormais
interdit au Congrès ainsi que sur les
téléphones des fonctionnaires la
Commission européenne le Parlement
européen certains gouvernements aussi
comme le gouvernement danois ont
interdit à leur personnel d'utiliser Tik
Tok et en France est-ce que vous en tant
que ministre vous me dites j'ai pas
TikTok est-ce que d'autres on voit que
certains de vos collègues utilisent Tik
Tok je pense à Emmanuel Macron un compte
TikTok Elisabeth borne Gérald Darmanin
je pourrais citer Marlène Schiappa li
Véran ce que c'est pas dangereux que les
ministres et Tik Tok sur leur téléphone
d'abord c'est bon de rappeler que en
Europe nous avons des règles et nous
exigeons que les données des
utilisateurs européens soient traités en
Europe il est avéré que aujourd'hui
certaines données de d'utilisateurs de
Tik Tok peuvent être traités peuvent
être manipulés à l'extérieur de l'Union
européenne et c'est inacceptable c'est
la raison pour laquelle une enquête est
ouverte par la CNIL l'irlandaise le
gendarme des données irlandais sur
interpellation du gendarme des données
français c'est la raison pour laquelle
hier a commencé une mission une
commission d'enquête sur Tik Tok et
c'est la raison pour laquelle aussi nous
avons demandé à ce que les dirigeants de
Tik Tok s'engagent à ce que courant 2023
les données des utilisateurs européens
soient traités en Europe je recevrai
dans quelques jours les dirigeants de
Tik Tok pour obtenir de leur part un
calendrier précis de conformité à ça en
attendant est-ce que en tant que
ministre du numérique vous recommandez à
vos collègues je sais pas au
parlementaire au fonctionnaires à tous
ceux qui pourraient avoir des données
sensibles sur leur téléphone de
désinstaller Tik Tok moi ce que je
constate c'est sur mon téléphone
professionnel demande du gouvernement il
ne met pas possible de d'installer des
réseaux sociaux c'est le cas de les os
des autres membres du gouvernement il y
a ensuite pour les autres agents des
ministères dans certains ministères une
interdiction générale de tous les
réseaux sociaux une réflexion est en
cours au gouvernement pour étendre cette
interdiction générale à d'autres
téléphones agents mais ça ne se résume
pas à Tik Tok et ça ne se résume pas aux
agents publics ma priorité c'est de
faire faire en sorte que les données des
Européens quelle que soit l'application
et quel que soit leur profession soit
bien traités en Europe et donc on
retient Jeannot le barreau et donc vous
comptez sur TiK ToK on va le dire en
2023 pour faire des efforts comme ça sur
la protection des données sur la
transparence en tout cas au niveau des
données cette année et que vous
soutiendrez donc un cette proposition de
loi c'est le groupe horizon qu'il a
dépose mais le gouvernement la
soutiendra pour fixer une majorité
numérique à 15 ans et on attend dans les
mois qui viennent aussi ce contrôle
parental par défaut c'est ça sur tous
les nouveaux appareils surtout les
smartphones voilà vos vos comment dire
vos annonces concrètes ce matin pour
protéger nos ados et les enfants plus
globalement face aux réseaux sociaux et
à Tik Tok qui est aujourd'hui dans le
viseur merci beaucoup Jean-Noël bar